il ya cinquante ans le parking de
l'hypermarché était déjà plaint pas de
parking pas de business disait alors le
fondateur de l'enseigné ça s'est vérifié
aujourd'hui les modèles de voitures ont
changé mais le parking est toujours très
fréquenté les anciennes sont maintenant
à l'intérieur pour servir de décor à cet
anniversaire
c'était au milieu des années 60 le maire
de la commune roger rémond apprenait
alors que le fondateur de carrefour
voulait ouvrir un magasin en province du
coup il est allé le voir il est parti à
anzhi et l'a convaincu d'installer son
père frattini il fallait en 68
anne-marie pescayre et secrétaire
générale à la mairie
je suis là pour aider à construire sa
ville en quelque sorte ça et du coup
dans la la possibilité d'installer un
carrefour à quétigny c'était quelque
chose d'extraordinaire ça permettait de
lancer une grande croissance commerciale
ce qui était quelque chose tout à fait
intéressante puisque on engageait ont
lancé une ville car ça n'était pas qu'un
magasin qui s'installait c'était la
locomotive de toute une zone d'activité
commerciale
le magasin et au fil du temps et bien le
magasin arrivée de s'agrandir depuis
cinquante ans un développement
commercial qui allait aussi devenir une
véritable manne financière pour le
village à grands coups de taxe
professionnelle
ces entreprises paient bien sûr ce que
la taxe professionnelle que la ville
percevaient à l'époque entièrement et
c'est par le ce financement en tout cas
a permis des réalisations sociales
sportives culturelles de la ville de
quetigny pour l'économique au service de
la population
et voilà comment un village de 500
habitants allaient multiplier sa
population par 20 en quelques décennies
la plus forte progression de la région
grâce à une zone commerciale qui reste
parmi les plus actives de bourgogne
franche comté